-Bonsoir et bienvenue.
Ravie de vous retrouver
pour une émission
aux odeurs de sable chaud
et de grand large.
A la veille des grandes vacances,
nous nous intéressons
au tourisme de masse.
Nous n'avons jamais autant voyagé,
Raphaël Hitier ?
-Oui, en 2019,
1,5 milliard de personnes
ont fait du tourisme
sur cette planète.
C'est 60 fois plus
que dans les années 50.
Sur ce laps de temps,
les retombées économiques du voyage
ont été multipliées par 600.
-Autant dire que les voyages
font toujours autant rêver.
La France est même
la première destination touristique
au monde.
Seul bémol : le tourisme
est responsable à lui seul
de 8 % des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre dans le monde.
Au fait, maman,
j'ai arrêté l'avion.
Générique
...
Des villes prises d'assaut,
des littoraux bétonnés ou pollués,
des monuments assaillis,
des plages bondées comme le métro,
un jour de grève...
Chacun exige son bout de paradis,
sa photo
et son selfie souvenir,
jusqu'au sommet du mont Blanc
ou de l'Everest.
Un même scénario
se répète toujours :
des riverains excédés
et des écosystèmes
de plus en plus fragilisés.
Comment sauver nos vacances
sans ruiner la planète ?
Existe-t-il un tourisme durable
à impact positif ?
Faut-il tout bonnement revoir
notre façon de voyager moins, mieux,
autrement et plus près ?
L'eurodéputée écologiste
et présidente de la commission
des transports et du tourisme,
Karima Delli,
le fondateur de Voyageurs du Monde,
de l'office
du tourisme de Paris,
Jean-François Rial,
et le maire
du plus beau village au monde,
d'après le magazine américain
Travel + Leisure,
Richard Kitaeff, édile de Gordes,
sont avec nous.
Avant de vous laisser
la parole,
partons à Marseille,
où un vent d'hostilité s'est levé
contre les bateaux de croisière,
qui peuvent accueillir
jusqu'à 9000 passagers,
mais dont l'omniprésence exaspère
les riverains.
Ils cracheraient leur fumée
au mépris de l'environnement
et de la santé.
La justice a été saisie
pour mise en danger d'autrui,
écocide et pollution marine.
Le Tout oppose d'Alexis Breton,
Jawar Nadi et Ibar Aibar.
-Le Vieux-Port de Marseille,
en début d'après-midi.
Un groupe de touristes
vient de débarquer
et attend patiemment le car
qui va les faire visiter.
-Vous avez combien de temps
pour visiter la ville ?
-Une journée.
-Nous sommes là jusqu'à 17h,
et après, on rentre.
-Ces visiteurs sont
ce que l'on appelle
des "croisiéristes".
Depuis Savone,
dans le nord de l'Italie,
ils ont embarqué
sur un paquebot gigantesque
vers Barcelone.
-On a quatre jours
pour tout faire.
Demain, c'est fini,
on rentre à Savone.
-C'est une mini croisière.
Musique exotique
-Marseille accueille de plus en plus
de touristes comme eux.
1,8 million chaque année.
La ville est
la 1re destination
des paquebots en France.
-Nous ne serions jamais venus ici
sans les croisières.
-On connaissait Nice.
-Oui, Nice, on connaît,
mais nous ne sommes jamais venus
à Marseille.
C'est beau.
-Les croisiéristes n'ont rien
à préparer.
300 euros par personne
et par séjour,
et le tour-opérateur
s'occupe de tout.
Des visites, des audio guides...
-C'est beau !
-...et quelques
points de chute connus.
-Papa, approche-toi.
-On n'a pas à réfléchir,
en croisière.
On quitte sa maison
pour voir de très belles choses.
Tout est programmé,
c'est super.
-Les croisières,
le symbole du tourisme de masse.
Pour eux, c'est l'occasion
de voyager pour pas cher,
mais pour certains habitants,
ces bateaux géants sont
un cauchemar.
Dans le monde,
près de 500 bateaux de croisière
naviguent sur toutes les mers,
de plus en plus nombreux et gros.
Certains peuvent accueillir
jusqu'à 9000 passagers,
dans un centre commercial géant.
Ici, une piste de karting
sur le bateau.
Là, une salle de spectacle,
un spot de surf,
une tyrolienne,
des dizaines de bars
et de restaurants
et des stars embauchées
pour en faire la pub :
Shakira ou Penélope Cruz,
sourire aux lèvres,
et en tenue légère.
Ces monstres marins rejettent
des quantités phénoménales
de gaz à effet de serre
et de polluants atmosphériques.
En un an, un seul paquebot émet
autant de CO2 que 10 000 voitures.
Par ailleurs,
ils se rendent responsables
d'accidents spectaculaires,
au point que Venise
leur a interdit l'accès
au centre historique,
et d'autres villes y réfléchissent.
Loisir qui détruit la planète,
source de plaisir
et de développement économique...
Deux visions s'opposent.
D'un côté,
Christophe Castaner,
ancien ministre
et président du Grand Port Maritime
de Marseille, de l'autre,
Fanny Pointet, de l'ONG écologiste
Transport et environnement.
-Le transport maritime,
les bateaux de croisière
avec tout le reste,
c'est environ 3 % des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre mondiales,
autant que l'aviation.
C'est un problème majeur
pour le climat.
-Je reste quelqu'un
qui croit dans l'hédonisme,
et je sais l'importance
des croisières.
C'est le voyage d'exception
des classes moyennes
dans notre pays,
parce que
c'est un voyage d'exception
qui n'est pas forcément cher.
-Non loin du Vieux-Port
de Marseille,
quelques membres de Stop croisières
sont rassemblés.
-Y A D'LA REVOLTE DANS L'AIR
LE CLIMAT C'EST NOTRE AFFAIRE
-Ce collectif créé l'année dernière
s'est fait connaître
grâce à un coup d'éclat.
Avec 12 kayaks,
ils ont bloqué pendant 2 heures
l'entrée dans le port de l'un
des plus gros paquebots du monde.
*-Ils se battent pour tout le monde,
pour le vivant !
-Depuis,
ils ont déposé plainte contre X
pour mise en danger
de la vie d'autrui,
pollution marine et écocide.
-Ce que nous voulons,
nous, les habitants,
c'est respirer un air pur,
un air qui soit vivable,
parce que depuis des années,
les gens sont malades des poumons,
et maintenant,
on comprend pourquoi.
-Nous sommes à L'Estaque,
au nord de la ville.
Chantal est l'une des membres
de Stop croisières.
Elle vit depuis 32 ans
dans ce quartier avec vue
sur le chantier naval.
-Il y en a toute l'année.
Un petit peu moins l'hiver,
bien évidemment,
mais on en a toute l'année.
Là, c'est un petit bateau.
Il est minuscule.
Quand il y a
les bateaux de croisière,
on voit plus les îles du Frioul,
en fait,
tellement c'est monstrueux.
-Ces gros navires seraient
responsables, d'après Chantal,
d'autres nuisances bien plus graves.
-Je me réveille quand même
quasiment tous les jours
avec une sensation
de gueule de bois.
J'ai le système hépatique
un peu fragile.
Donc, j'ai du mal
à évacuer les toxines.
C'est une des premières choses.
Ca génère des maux de tête,
des nausées,
une sensation de fatigue.
C'est des symptômes assez communs
aux gens qui m'entourent,
aux gens qui entourent
le port autonome, en fait.
-A partir de quand
vous avez commencé
à avoir ces problèmes ?
-Depuis qu'il y a de plus en plus
de trafic maritime à Marseille.
Ca correspond
à une dizaine d'années,
et c'est très renforcé
depuis - je dirais -
quatre ou cinq ans.
-Aujourd'hui,
aucune preuve ne permet de lier
les symptômes de Chantal
aux paquebots de croisière.
Selon Santé publique France,
en revanche, la pollution de l'air
est responsable
de 40 000 décès prématurés par an,
notamment à cause
des particules fines.
-Les bateaux de croisière,
ce sont les bateaux
les plus émissifs.
Ils naviguent près des côtes.
Ils ont un impact
sur la qualité de l'air
qu'on respire.
C'est essentiellement lié au rejet
de polluants atmosphériques
que sont les oxydes de soufre,
les oxydes d'azote
et les particules fines.
Tout ça, ça crée
des problèmes respiratoires
et des morts prématurées
chaque an.
-Avec ses voisins,
Chantal a installé un capteur
pour mesurer le taux
de particules fines dans l'air.
Chaque jour,
elle consulte les résultats.
-Là, on voit qu'hier, à midi,
il y avait des pics.
Aujourd'hui, avec le mistral,
c'est plus tranquille, quoi.
Tout ce qui dépasse les pointillés,
on est au-dessus
des pollutions tolérées, quoi.
Donc, on voit
qu'on dépasse souvent.
-Une semaine après notre tournage,
Chantal nous a envoyé cette vidéo,
qu'elle a filmée depuis la rue
située juste devant chez elle.
A l'image, on distingue
5 paquebots de croisière
qui stationnent dans le port,
une situation habituelle
en haute saison.
A la date de la vidéo,
les émissions de particules fines
atteignent des records.
La moyenne du week-end se situe
à 23,9 microgrammes par mètre cube,
1,5 fois plus que la norme fixée
par l'Organisation Mondiale
de la Santé.
Le 14 mai, un pic atteint même
les 75 microgrammes par mètre cube,
soit 5 fois plus
que la norme internationale.
Une pollution dangereuse,
mais le port de Marseille
pense avoir trouvé
la solution au problème.
Nous avons rendez-vous
avec Sophie Rouan,
qui dirige le département
Voyageurs et énergie au sein
du Grand Port Maritime de Marseille.
-Bonjour, monsieur.
Là, on est à l'intérieur
du terminal croisières.
C'est un terminal
qu'on a prévu d'équiper,
à l'échéance 2025,
de connexions électriques.
Dans ce terminal,
on va aussi produire
de l'électricité photovoltaïque,
sur ces anciens hangars.
-Pourquoi vous devez électrifier ?
-En fait, tous les navires,
historiquement,
utilisent leurs propres moteurs
dans les ports
pour avoir de l'électricité à bord.
Quand on a beaucoup
de passagers à bord,
on a besoin
de beaucoup d'électricité,
et donc, ils utilisent aujourd'hui
leurs groupes électrogènes internes
qui sont à la fois
des sources de pollution,
puisqu'ils brûlent du diesel,
et aussi, ça produit du CO2,
des gaz à effet de serre.
Donc, ce qu'on propose
à ces navires,
c'est de remplacer
leurs groupes électrogènes
par une connexion électrique
qui ne produit pas de polluants
et qui permet
de décarboner l'atmosphère.
-Le port de Marseille est
le premier de la Méditerranée
en matière d'électrification.
Nous avons déjà électrifié
la totalité des bateaux de passagers
qui vont vers la Corse.
Au mois de juin de cette année,
c'est l'ensemble des ferries
qui vont vers les pays
du nord de l'Afrique,
et l'Algérie en particulier.
Nous commencerons
à investir massivement,
50 millions d'euros en tout,
pour électrifier les quais
de croisières d'ici 2025.
-Le branchement à quai,
ça va demander d'énormes quantités
d'énergie disponible.
C'est une transition
qui doit être prise en compte
par tous les opérateurs économiques,
pour pouvoir donner suffisamment
de courant à ces navires
sans poser de problème pour fournir
de l'électricité à la ville.
Ca va demander des investissements
colossaux pour les ports.
-D'après le port de Marseille,
les travaux sont financés à 100 %
par de l'argent public.
A partir de 2025,
deux paquebots pourront
se brancher simultanément
sur le quai,
mais si d'autres accostent
au même moment,
ils devront laisser tourner
leur moteur en permanence.
La pollution de l'air
ne diminuera qu'en partie.
Pour les pro-croisières,
on préfère mettre en avant
les bienfaits de ces bateaux.
-Allez, on y va.
-Jean-François Suhas est un pilote
dont le travail est d'aider
les gros navires à accoster.
-Allez, c'est bon ?
-Il est également
le président du Club
de la Croisière,
qui milite pour le développement
de cette industrie.
-La croisière, c'est une histoire
qui a à peu près 25 ans.
Les premiers bateaux,
il y avait en gros
une cinquantaine d'escales
avec 20 000 passagers
au début des années 2000,
à la fin des années 90.
Aujourd'hui, 23 ans après,
on est à 2 millions,
et à 600 escales.
-Des touristes qui ont forcément,
selon lui,
un impact positif
sur l'économie de la ville.
-Quand vous avez 5000 personnes,
ils vont se déplacer dans la ville,
utiliser les transports en commun,
les taxis,
se rendre dans les commerces,
dans les musées, etc.
Quand vous avez la chance
qu'on vous amène
400 000 Américains,
qui ne seraient jamais venus,
et qui vont passer la journée
à Marseille,
je crois que ça mérite
d'avoir un regard dessus.
Un regard critique,
mais aussi bienveillant.
Ce sont des gens qui voyagent,
qui découvrent notre culture.
-Sur l'ensemble
du territoire, nous savons
que les croisières génèrent
à peu près entre 300 et 400 millions
d'euros de retombées.
En emplois directs et indirects,
c'est près de 2400 emplois
qui sont directement impactés
par l'activité croisière.
Allez sur le Vieux-Port
et interrogez les riverains,
mais aussi
les restaurateurs du Vieux-Port,
et ils vous diront l'importance
des bateaux de croisière.
-Eh bien,
c'est ce que nous avons fait.
Suivant les conseils
de M. Castaner,
nous nous sommes rendus
dans Le Panier,
l'un des quartiers
les plus touristiques.
Lukas Vollmy,
un vendeur de vin et membre
du collectif Stop croisières,
nous accompagne faire
le tour des commerçants
qui ne profitent pas
des milliers de croisiéristes
qui passent chaque année.
-A chaque fois,
quand ils rentrent en boutique,
ils sont attirés
par les bijoux, le corail,
mais ils disent toujours :
"Pas le temps. Il faut y aller."
-Si les grands bateaux
étaient pas là,
il y aurait une différence
pour vous ?
-Honnêtement, je pense pas.
-Même chose
chez les voisins cavistes.
-Au niveau du pastis, non.
Ils n'ont pas le droit
d'amener de l'alcool à bord.
-Règles strictes,
manque de temps,
les croisiéristes ont également
tout à disposition à bord,
des souvenirs
à la nourriture.
Résultat, à Marseille :
les commerçants qui vendent
de petits objets pas chers
s'en sortent le mieux. Ici,
des biscuits
à la fleur d'oranger.
-Bonjour. Je voulais savoir
si vous recevez
des croisiéristes ici.
-Alors, oui.
C'est quelque chose qui est...
Qui est significatif
en nombre de personnes.
D'un coup,
on va se retrouver avec 50 personnes
dans notre petite boutique
mais ça n'amène pas
un chiffre important.
Après, économiquement, c'est sûr
qu'on est mieux avec que sans.
-On sacrifie beaucoup
notre santé
pour amener un bénéfice économique
qui est très discutable.
Il y en a certainement un peu,
mais c'est mineur.
Je vois pas pourquoi
les Marseillais devraient
vendre leur santé pour ça.
-Malgré l'opposition
de la mairie de Marseille,
le port autonome
ne veut pas diminuer ou limiter
la fréquentation
des paquebots de croisière.
-La croisière est
une activité industrielle,
donc au même titre que les autres
activités économiques,
elle doit se décarboner
et rapidement.
C'est vraiment la condition
sine qua non
pour que cette activité
continue d'exister.
-Il y a des gens qui sont
globalement contre les loisirs.
Au fond, les loisirs,
ce serait mal.
La piscine, c'est mal.
Les croisières, c'est mal.
Le ski, c'est mal.
Je trouve que cette espèce
de revendication-sanction
permanente
contre tout ce qui relève
de ce qui n'est pas utile
ou obligatoire
est une vraie menace,
même d'un point de vue
sociologique.
Il y a de nombreuses
dont on peut considérer
qu'elles ne sont pas utiles :
la lecture, la radio,
la culture,
la musique, le sport.
Chacun peut avoir son avis.
Je pense
que tout ça est utile,
surtout au nom des libertés
individuelles de chacun.
-Vous êtes d'accord
avec M. Castaner ?
Les loisirs sont une liberté
et un droit inaliénable
quoi qu'il en coûte ?
-Pas du tout.
Je trouve son point de vue
caricatural.
Tout est dit
quand il parle d'hédonisme.
On assiste à une transformation
entre un tourisme éducatif,
l'origine du tourisme,
et un tourisme récréatif.
Ca, c'est un peu compliqué
parce qu'on entre vraiment
dans la découverte artificielle
des lieux.
C'est le problème
de ce tourisme.
-Un hédonisme économique.
-Monsieur le maire
a complètement raison.
Moi, je suis voyagiste.
Je suis un fou de voyage.
Je suis un fou d'hédonisme
et du voyage.
Je suis désolé de dire qu'il dit
un peu n'importe quoi.
C'est-à-dire qu'on ne peut pas
faire n'importe quoi
s'il y a conséquences
pour les tiers,
les habitants, la planète,
l'écologie...
Bien sûr que le voyage,
c'est fantastique,
mais avec ces discours,
on tue le voyage.
C'est le problème. Certaines choses
sont pas acceptables.
-Ca tue déjà les gens.
C'est ça qui est...
-Oui, Karima a raison.
Les particules fines jouent.
-Ils disent qu'il faut consommer
du voyage à n'importe quel prix.
Je suis désolée, non.
Au prix de la santé des gens ?
Il y a une dame
qui dit dans votre reportage,
qui est assez fou :
"On n'a pas réfléchi.
On est dans le bateau,
"on n'a pas à réfléchir."
C'est là la dure réalité.
La dure réalité,
c'est qu'on vend une image
totalement idyllique.
Pour la première fois
- merci pour votre reportage -,
je vois qu'il y a
des courses de...
-De karts.
-...de karts, voilà.
C'est assez dingue.
Derrière
- je le dis en tant que présidente
de la commission
de transport et de tourisme -,
là, j'ai un problème de fond,
parce qu'il y a
un double impact.
On montre aux yeux de tous
l'absurdité du tourisme démesuré,
et je suis sûre
que vous serez d'accord.
La deuxième chose,
c'est la santé des gens.
On parle d'oxyde d'azote
et des particules.
-On a des études d'impact ?
-Oui. Au niveau européen,
le transport maritime,
c'est 60 000 morts...
prématurées,
mais le coût doit
nous faire réfléchir,
en tout cas.
On parle de 58 milliards...
Milliards !
...d'euros. Je pense
qu'on peut faire autre chose.
-De coûts de santé liés ?
D'accord.
-Une plainte a été déposée pour,
en effet,
établir s'il y a un lien
entre les pollutions générées
et les symptômes recensés.
Mais à l'étranger,
plusieurs villes,
notamment le centre
de Venise et Palma de Majorque,
ont pris des mesures fortes
et interdit les paquebots.
Il faut réguler comme ça ?
-Oui !
Faut attendre les drames.
Pourquoi Venise décide d'interdire ?
On se souvient de cette image
extraordinaire,
de ce giga-paquebot,
ou n'importe,
qui arrive
aux portes de Venise
et qui manque d'arracher,
notamment,
cette fameuse jetée,
qui est extraordinaire.
Ca a été
le signal d'alarme
et les populations ont dit :
"Ca suffit."
-Là où les croisiéristes
ne se rendent pas compte,
et l'industrie du voyage en général,
c'est qu'en fait,
ils tuent leur propre produit.
Mais les premiers responsables,
quand même,
je veux le dire,
c'est les clients,
les clients qui achètent ça.
Je veux quand même dire
que les croisières,
elles ont beaucoup de défauts.
Moi, c'est pas du tout
mon truc.
On n'en vend pas du tour
chez Voyageurs du monde.
Mais ça a quelques qualités.
Ca permet aux gens de pas changer
d'hôtel tous les soirs.
Les personnes âgées
adorent ça.
Ca pourrait être très bien.
Par exemple,
si vous circulez...
Si vous changez de...
d'énergie de propulsion.
L'hydrogène vert
serait l'idéal.
-Vous croyez vraiment
au carburant vert ?
-Mais bien sûr !
Le biogaz...
-Des paquebots à voile,
des piles à combustibles,
le gaz naturel liquéfié,
ça va sauver le secteur ?
-Ca va prendre du temps.
-Prenons le biogaz.
Il y a des bateaux,
des gros bateaux de croisières,
qui circulent au biogaz.
C'est pas parfait mais ça divise
par 2 les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre.
C'est un premier pas.
Et puis, ça n'émet pas,
Karima pourra me contredire,
de particules fines.
-L'EGL produit en effet
-20 à -25 %
d'émissions de CO2
que le fioul lourd,
mais il est composé de méthane
dont l'effet de serre
est plus élevé.
-Peut-être...
-Sans compter les difficultés
liées...
-C'est pas du biogaz.
Ca n'a rien à voir.
-Ca reste
des énergies fossiles.
-C'est un progrès,
et l'idéal serait l'hydrogène vert,
évidemment,
là, vous êtes tranquilles.
Ca a cette capacité,
contrairement aux avions,
d'en mettre autant
que vous voulez. Si on crée
de l'hydrogène par l'électricité...
-On en est loin.
-Mais non !
-La législation européenne
est là pour activer.
On est en train de mettre
en place la législation.
On est en train de dire
que tous les bateaux,
quels qu'ils soient
au niveau européen,
vont devoir être,
à partir de 2030, électrifiés
à quais à cause
de l'impact sur la population.
-Je ne parle pas que de ça.
-Ensuite...
-Je parle de la propulsion
pendant le voyage.
Ca aussi, ça émet.
-Sur la propulsion
lors du voyage,
il y a aujourd'hui des solutions
qui sont en train d'arriver.
Par exemple, en France...
-A quelle échéance ?
-C'est à nous de savoir.
Moi, je dis que l'alternative
ou les alternatives,
c'est par exemple le Vélic.
Ce sont notamment
les bateaux à voile.
Aujourd'hui,
on a une capacité industrielle...
extraordinaire
à le faire.
Le problème que nous avons,
c'est que tout ça,
il va falloir le reconvertir,
parce que c'est du fioul lourd.
Derrière, il y a une nouvelle
industrie d'économie circulaire
à mettre en place,
former des salariés etc.
Et il faut se poser
la question de la cadence.
Je suis désolée,
dans le port de Marseille,
comment se fait-il que l'on accepte
cinq paquebots à la fois ?
Enfin c'est la question
de la taille.
On n'est pas d'accord d'avoir
des espèces de tanks sur nos routes.
Sur la mer, c'est pareil.
-Un mot de l'électrique.
La question des quais.
Les travaux sont financés
à 100 % par l'argent public.
Certains regrettent
que les armateurs
ne soient pas mis à contribution
selon la logique du pollueur payeur.
Qu'en pensez-vous ?
-A partir du moment
où on développe,
quand je dis "on",
ce sont les voyagistes
- c'est pas une critique -,
les opérateurs du secteur,
la destination de manière
obsessionnelle,
on veut en vendre
comme on vend des cartes postales.
On ne peut pas en même temps
vouloir proclamer la protéger
et être sûr
que l'on réussira
la transition écologique.
Le financement devrait
être assuré exclusivement
par les armateurs
et par les opérateurs.
-C'est très discutable, M. le maire.
-Vraiment ?
Alors qu'on demande
la sobriété aux Français,
on peut s'étonner que l'argent
public serve à alimenter
les pistes de ski,
les patinoires
ou les simulateurs de surf
de ces monstres marins.
-Je ne dis pas que je suis contre,
je dis que ça dépend...
Si on veut...
Si on veut décarboner l'économie,
tous azimuts,
il est pas complètement anormal
que les pouvoirs publics
et les fonds publics y participent.
-A 100 % ?
-Pas forcément à 100 %,
mais pour l'accélérer.
Nous, on pénalise,
en Europe.
Aux Etats-Unis,
ils donnent des crédits d'impôt
pour décarboner,
et ils vont plus vite.
C'est un problème.
Sur les vols intérieurs américains,
en 2050,
c'est 100 % de carburant
de synthèse.
Nous, on discute encore
à 1 ou 2 % à l'intérieur
pour les carburants.
-Si vous augmentez
l'activité du secteur,
vous ne décarbonez pas.
Vous pouvez changer
les carburants,
mais si vous augmentez l'activité
à ce rythme,
vous ne décarbonez pas.
-Ce n'est pas vrai,
ce que vous dites.
Je suis désolé.
Si vous voulez décarboner...
Prenons les jets privés.
Je propose
qu'ils soient à 100 %
de carburant de synthèse.
Ca marche tout de suite à 100 %.
Désolé...
-100 %, non.
-A 100 %, Raphaël.
Je connais mon sujet.
A 100 %.
-Moi aussi, je connais le sujet.
-Si vous produisez
de l'électricité verte
et que vous en générez
de l'hydrogène vert,
vous allez décarboner à 95 %.
-La production,
mais pas les moyens.
Ce n'est pas grave.
-Bien sûr que si,
les moyens de production !
Brouhaha
Je ne suis pas d'accord !
J'en ai marre
d'entendre des âneries.
En parlant de production,
on dit qu'on ne peut pas
la décarboner.
Ce n'est pas vrai !
Si on produit
avec de l'électricité verte...
Et c'est pour ça
que je suis pour le nucléaire
et que je considère
que je suis un écolo engagé.
Je suis à 100 %
pour le nucléaire.
Pour décarboner,
il faut de l'électricité décarbonée.
Et donc...
-Je partage
une partie du point de vue,
mais à l'échelle de 2030...
-Je continue...
-Il faut avancer.
-En 2030,
il n'est pas question
d'avoir réduit de 100 %.
Ca ne vous a pas échappé.
-Non, mais de répondre
aux accords de Paris.
-Si vous reprenez
les accords de Paris
et que vous vous mettez
sur une ligne à 2 degrés
- le 1,5 degré, j'adore -,
mais il faut baisser de 20 % !
On peut monter les trafics
et baisser de 20 %,
contrairement
à ce que vous dites.
Brouhaha
-Un mot, Karima ?
-Ce n'est pas la solution !
Sur les jets privés,
vous les prenez aujourd'hui,
c'est 14 fois...
14 fois plus
en termes d'émissions...
-On est d'accord, Karima.
Je propose...
-L'alternative,
elle est simple.
Il faut relancer le train !
-Le problème du train,
en admettant que l'on ait l'offre
et les connexions à Roissy,
qu'on n'a pas...
On admet ça.
Si on remplace
tout ce qu'on peut remplacer,
on va réduire de 10 %
les émissions de gaz...
-Pas seulement.
-Si, Karima, sur l'avion.
Le train va vous remplacer
du court
et du moyen-courrier.
Le sujet, c'est le long-courrier.
C'est pour cela
que je veux imposer le carburant
de synthèse aux jets privés
pour qu'ils nous créent une filière
qui nous permette de décarboner
le long-courrier.
-Je pense trois trucs, très vite.
Il faut absolument
interdire tout
ce qui est alternatif.
La Convention citoyenne parlait
de l'alternative à 4 heures.
-Je suis d'accord.
-Il faut que la France arrête
de nous bloquer notre texte
sur le ciel unique européen.
-D'accord !
-C'est quoi, ce truc ?
On optimise l'ensemble
des flux européens pour les réduire.
-10 % de CO2 au niveau européen.
-Je partage
tout ce que vous dites...
Je partage
tout ce que vous dites.
Si on veut décarboner l'avion
avec tous les outils qu'on a,
si on n'utilise pas
de façon massive
le carburant de synthèse,
on n'y arrivera pas.
-Revenons à terre,
s'il vous plaît.
Richard, votre village,
Gordes, a été sacré
plus beau village au monde
par ce magazine américain.
Certaines villes et villages
refusent d'être distingués
par crainte
des hordes incontrôlables.
D'autres font carrément
du démarketing
comme les calanques de Marseille
ou Aix pour décourager les foules.
Vous craignez pas
la surfréquentation ?
-La surfréquentation,
on la connaît déjà depuis 20 ans.
On avait déjà été distingué
par des labels
comme plus beau village de France
ou des partenariats
comme avec Netflix
et "Emily in Paris".
-Quel a été l'impact
de ce tournage sur Gordes ?
-Nous,
on a négocié avec Netflix
l'occupation des lieux
et des parkings.
Ca n'a pas été
à somme nulle pour eux.
On a obtenu des sommes importantes
pour la commune.
Il n'y a pas eu
de difficultés avec ce tournage.
Ce qui est intéressant,
c'est l'ambiguïté
lorsque l'on veut effectivement
interdire l'accès au village,
parfois.
-A Marseille,
à Porquerolles ou en Corse,
on commence à contingenter.
Il faut réserver
trois jours à l'avance
pour admirer la calanque de Sugiton
dont l'accès est limité.
Ca ne vous inspire pas ?
-C'est quelque chose
que l'on a demandé
à certains opérateurs privés,
comme l'abbaye de Sénanque,
le système
de réservations en amont...
-Elle est prise d'assaut.
-Les exemples que vous donnez
sont des exemples
où le tourisme de masse
s'est révélé destructeur,
comme dans les calanques. A Gordes,
ça ne pose pas ces problèmes.
Tout est fait
pour anticiper cela.
-Ce que vous dites est vrai,
mais il y a plein
de villes en Europe
où les maires ont pris des mesures
un peu drastiques.
Sympa, mais drastiques.
Je pense notamment
au maire de Dubrovnik,
cette cité médiévale
de "Game Of Thrones".
Tout le monde veut faire sa photo.
-Ils ont installé
des compteurs à l'entrée.
-Ils ont pris les règles
de l'ONU et ils ont dit :
"Pour le tourisme durable,
"il y a un certain nombre
de touristes à accepter."
l'ONU dit que selon la surface,
c'est 8000 touristes, eux,
ils ont dit 4000.
-Est-on vraiment
en capacité de recevoir
autant de monde ?
Nos infrastructures
suivent-elles ?
Quel est l'impact
pour l'environnement ?
-C'est une question
qu'on se pose tous les jours
avec les services de l'Etat,
et par rapport à l'Etat central,
en fait.
Je vous donne l'exemple
que je connais, celui de Gordes.
Nous avons près d'un million
de visiteurs attendus cette année.
On n'est même pas 15 personnes
pour les accueillir.
Il y a sept gendarmes,
deux policiers municipaux
et quelques saisonniers.
En tant que maire, je suis amené
à interpeller, à verbaliser.
On se sent démunis.
Il suffirait de changer
certains éléments
dans la réglementation.
-Par exemple ?
-Un exemple typique.
On vient photographier
des panoramas.
Il y a de l'encombrement.
Il suffirait
qu'on nous autorise
à adapter une verbalisation vidéo,
parce qu'on a le droit
de la vidéoprotection
mais pas de la verbalisation vidéo,
ou qu'on nous permette
d'adopter des amendes
plus dissuasives
que les 11 euros.
-Pourquoi ne pas envisager
un système de réservation
en ligne, un péage à l'entrée,
ou une piétonisation ?
-Les péages,
c'est pour les zoos,
selon moi.
On n'est pas un parc d'attractions,
on est pas Disney Gordes...
-Avec un million
de touristes par an...
-Mettre en place
des péages,
il faut que ce soit
une réflexion
des services de l'Etat.
Rien ne nous autorise
à supprimer la liberté
d'aller et venir,
mais là où je suis d'accord,
c'est qu'il faudrait réguler
le système touristique
et la sacro-sainte liberté
d'aller et venir
connaît déjà ses limites.
Pourquoi on peut constamment
aller et venir
dans tous les coins du globe,
parfois de manière destructrice ?
Je regarde les tweets
de notre ami qui montrent
des dunes,
des paysages majestueux.
Est-ce qu'ils sont faits
pour être montrés par une société
de consommation spectaculaire ?
-Là, c'est mon sujet.
-Je vous sens trépigner.
Je vous donne
la parole.
-Le tourisme de masse
et les surconcentrations des sites,
c'est catastrophique.
C'est l'antithèse totale
de ce qu'il faut faire
dans le voyage.
Il faut avoir conscience,
je le dis souvent,
que 95 % de ceux qui voyagent
vont sur 5 % des sites
dans le monde.
Et encore, je pense
que je suis gentil.
Je pense qu'il faut appliquer
tous les systèmes
de quota possibles, même
s'ils ne vont pas tout résoudre.
Ils sont plus faciles
sur un site
type Sénanque ou la tour Eiffel
que sur une commune.
Le Mont-Saint-Michel,
c'est une commune,
Collonges-la-Rouge, Gordes,
ce sont des communes.
Moi, je pense
qu'il faut réfléchir à tous
les systèmes qui empêchent ça
parce que même avec des quotas,
même avec
des systèmes piétonniers,
vous êtes chez Disney.
C'est-à-dire que vous flinguez
l'authenticité de votre produit,
vous flinguez l'âme
de l'endroit, vous ennuyez les gens
des villages ou des villes
comme Dubrovnik,
ou à Barcelone
ou même à Paris.
A Paris, à la tour Eiffel,
ce n'est plus possible.
-C'est pas un produit.
-Il faut élargir
l'offre touristique ?
-Il faut faire plein de choses.
Il faut éduquer.
Il faut éduquer, et très fort.
Il faut que les clients arrêtent
de vouloir faire ça.
-Il faut éduquer les riches,
les plus riches d'abord.
-C'est tout le monde, Karima.
Non, c'est tout le monde.
C'est un problème de culture.
-C'est pas les pauvres
qui détruisent la planète.
-Il y a une corrélation
entre le prix des vacances
et la nuisance carbone.
-Laissez-moi finir.
Il faut éduquer tout le monde.
Il faut éduquer les clients,
les professionnels.
Mes confrères qui continuent
de programmer des tours...
Ce que me font les Américains
quand ils programment Paris,
j'hallucine.
Je veux qu'on vende Paris autrement,
qu'on vende les quartiers
où il y a pas de selfie.
Troisième chose...
-Peut-être qu'il faudrait arrêter
de vendre.
-Il faut réguler
par la loi.
Et il faut étendre les horaires.
Il faut étendre les horaires.
La tour Eiffel,
je dis 24/24, et les riches,
ça va faire plaisir
à Karima, ils vont y aller
à 11h du soir, payer cher,
ce qui permettra
de payer mieux les salariés
et d'avoir moins de masse.
-Vous parliez de quotas,
on va écouter
un promoteur de quotas.
-L'idée que même on puisse
prendre quatre vols
en avion dans une vie,
il y a un gros demi-siècle,
ça existait pas,
pour la population
dans son ensemble.
Donc ce truc qui paraît aujourd'hui
inconcevable, restrictive,
malthusien, triste sire,
casse-bonbons et j'en passe,
à une partie des gens
qui réagissent,
il faut se rendre compte
que c'est extrêmement récent
et qui partira avec le pétrole,
parce que quand on regarde
les alternatives techniques
dans l'aviation,
une fois qu'il y aura plus
de pétrole,
il y aura pas de quoi assurer
quatre vols dans une vie.
-Jean-Marc Jancovici
persiste à penser qu'il faut
des quotas de vols.
Ca vous fait bondir.
-Non, ça me fait
pas bondir.
Je connais très bien Jean-Marc.
J'ai de l'estime pour lui.
C'est un écologiste brillant,
mais je suis en désaccord complet.
On confond l'objectif et les moyens.
L'objectif, c'est de respecter
les accords du GIEC.
Je serai le premier
à toujours le dire.
-Un Français...
-Mais il a décidé des moyens.
Et moi, je trouve que son moyen
est le pire
parce que c'est un système chinois,
un système de note sociale
qui va être contourné.
Les riches vont plus voyager
parce que ça va tricher.
Je vais vous dire
un truc qui va vous choquer.
Je préférerais qu'on interdise
l'avion à son truc.
-Vous préconisez
une hausse du tarif
des billets ?
C'est ce que vous préconisez.
-On va pas les lister,
mais il y a 25 mesures
qui permettent de baisser
les émissions de gaz à effet
de serre de l'avion.
-Lesquelles ?
-Je vais vous donner un chiffre.
Voyageurs du monde,
entre 2019 et 2022,
a baissé ses émissions globales
sans offset, sans compensation,
sans l'absorption
que je fais en plus,
a baissé ses émissions
de 30 %, moitié effet
nombre de clients,
moitié effet optimisation
des moteurs, etc.
C'est pas mes chiffres.
-C'est lié à la pandémie, peut-être.
-Non, j'ai enlevé l'effet clients.
La moitié sur les 30,
c'est l'effet clients.
L'autre moitié,
c'est un chiffre d'affaires
constant.
En 2023, je vais faire plus
de chiffre qu'en 2019,
je vais avoir plus de clients
et des émissions plus faibles
de moins 10 %. Il y a les routes,
le Ciel unique européen,
comme l'a dit Karima,
les moteurs, etc.
Ca suffira pas.
-Clairement.
-Et il y a le trafic affaires
qui baisse.
Donc la vraie solution...
Le train, évidemment,
tout ça...
La solution, c'est les carburants
de synthèse.
Là où n'est pas d'accord
avec Jean-Marc,
c'est qu'il dit que c'est pas
possible à l'échelle.
Si, mais il y aura
un conflit d'usage
sur l'électricité verte
et les rejets.
Je suis d'accord, mais d'ici 2050,
on peut le faire.
Je dis que l'aérien
doit baisser ses émissions,
quel que soit le volume,
y compris s'il s'accroit
dans le cadre du GIEC,
et je suis contre cette solution.
Il y en a d'autres.
-La crème solaire,
dont on se tartine
abondamment toute la journée,
n'est pas neutre non plus.
C'est l'heure du Climatoscope.
-25 000 tonnes de crème solaire
se retrouvent dans les océans
chaque année.
Un chercheur français a calculé
que sur les plages de Marseille,
ça faisait 52 kilos de crème
par jour dans la mer.
Ca a l'air d'être une goutte d'eau
à l'échelle de la Méditerranée.
Mais pour la faune et la flore
qui tente de survivre,
c'est pas la fête.
-Quel est le problème ?
-Ce sont les substances
utilisées pour bloquer
les rayons solaires
qui sont assez particulières.
Je vais être technique.
-Hawaï.
-Hawaï en a interdit une partie,
à savoir les filtres organiques,
qui ont la capacité d'absorber
les rayons du soleil
et de transformer ça en chaleur.
Du coup, il y a des molécules
un peu exotiques
qu'on n'a pas envie de manger
quand on regarde la liste
toxicologique.
Et il y a les filtres minéraux
qui font des reflets
et renvoient
les UV, ce sont des oxydes
de zinc et de titane.
Donc deux populations
de molécules.
Et quand on va se baigner,
on disperse un petit cocktail
chimique autour de soi
à chaque fois.
-Avec quel impact ?
-L'impact le mieux documenté,
c'est celui sur les coraux.
On observe
que ça fait blanchir
les coraux,
raison pour laquelle à Hawaï,
ils ont interdit l'usage
de ces filtres organiques.
Tout est parti
d'une étude scientifique de 2008
d'une équipe italienne
qui a réussi, en faisant des tests
avec des filtres organiques,
à montrer qu'en petites quantités,
sur des coraux,
il y a du blanchiment.
En fait,
ces molécules réactivent
les virus dormants
présents dans les algues
qui sont en symbiose avec le corail.
Une vie un peu compliquée,
comme ça...
-C'est grave ?
-Oui dans le sens
où les coraux sont
ce qu'on appelle
des points chauds de biodiversité,
là où se concentre la vie marine,
donc à chaque fois
qu'un corail se meurt,
c'est toute la faune autour
qui trinque.
Alors la crème
n'est pas responsable
de tout,
mais ça en rajoute
une couche.
-Vous nous conseillez
d'arrêter la crème ?
-Certainement pas,
il y a
des études sur l'exposition
sans protection.
C'est une usine à cancer.
Il faut faire attention
en choisissant la crème,
en évitant les filtres organiques.
Préférez les filtres minéraux,
mais là encore,
ça commence à monter.
On se demande
si ça pose pas d'autres problèmes.
Il y a la résistante à l'eau,
ça évite d'en mettre trop
et de tartiner les coraux.
Il y a une dernière solution :
aller passer ses vacances
à l'ombre d'un grand chêne
dans le Berry, par exemple.
-Ou à Gordes.
-Gordes,
où la densité touristique,
le nombre de lits rapporté
à la population,
est de 193 %.
Le village arrive deuxième
du top 10 de la fréquentation
touristique
du département.
Les villageois le vivent bien ?
-Il y a 50 kilomètres carrés,
dans en réalité,
la visite touristique se diffuse
dans les hameaux,
dans cet univers de masse
de pierres sèches.
Il y a pas de difficulté majeure
sur la commune.
-A la mi-mai,
cinq bassins versants
du Vaucluse étaient
en alerte renforcée
et les sécheresses
se multiplient.
Le rationnement
de l'eau est une vraie question ?
-La surconsommation d'eau
est une des plaies du tourisme
de masse et c'est évident
que ça concerne Gordes
ave le nombre de piscines
que nous avons.
Le vrai problème, c'est pourquoi
l'Etat ne donne pas les moyens
aux élus locaux d'intervenir
réellement ?
Si on prend des arrêtés pour dire
qu'on doit pas remplir les piscines,
il faut pouvoir
les appliquer.
Si vous ne pouvez pas avoir
de moyen de contrôle,
c'est un voeu pieux.
Ca fait aussi partie
des difficultés des élus.
-L'autre difficulté,
ce sont les incendies.
Le Vaucluse est un département
à très haut risque d'incendie.
-Oui, c'est irresponsable,
comme le font
certains opérateurs,
de laisser déferler
des dizaines
de milliers de touristes
dans des vallons,
de créer des boucles vélos
qui sont dangereuses.
En cas de risque incendie,
même si on y met le maximum
de moyens, d'effectifs,
de réservoirs,
on n'arrivera pas
au risque zéro.
-J'arrive pas
à comprendre pourquoi
vous vous dites pas qu'il faut
réduire le nombre de touristes
parce qu'on va pas pouvoir remplir
toutes les piscines...
-C'est une question
au niveau des tours-opérateurs
et des offices de tourisme.
-Il faut que vous leur disiez
quels sont les autres
villages sublimes du Lubéron
à voir seuls plutôt que d'aller
à Gordes.
-On la fait.
Avec les maires du canton,
on s'était opposés
à la traduction
des documents touristiques locaux
en chinois.
Ca pose de vraies difficultés.
J'adore la Chine,
mais à partir du moment
où vous vendez une destination
à la Chine,
s'il y a que 0,1 % qui vient,
ça crée des problèmes.
On a vu ces images de Chinois
dans les champs de lavande.
Quand il sont
des dizaines de milliers,
c'est pas possible.
-Ils ont tué l'Islande.
-Le tourisme
est intercommunal.
-Quoi qu'il en soit, en France,
si on n'a pas de pétrole,
on a des idées pour promouvoir
un tourisme alternatif
et si possible régénératif
afin d'améliorer le destination
plutôt que de la défigurer.
L'hébergement de nos vacances
est responsable de 7 %
des émissions de CO2 du tourisme.
Certains en sont conscients.
40 % des Français se disent prêts
à payer plus cher
pour réduire leur impact.
Une appli les a pris au mot.
Le monde demain commence
et il est à portée de train.
La preuve par ce reportage
signé Jawar Nadi.
-A Saint-Germain-des-Essourts,
en Normandie,
au coeur d'une forêt privée
de 27 hectares
que l'on ne peut emprunter
qu'à pieds pour ne pas déranger
la nature,
voici Guillaume Jouffre
et Jean-François Turquan,
deux professionnels du tourisme
atypiques.
-On a la première cabane.
-Oui, c'est ça.
-Jean-François est le propriétaire
de neuf cabanes comme celle-ci,
perchées dans les arbres
à plusieurs mètres du sol.
-Ah ouais.
C'est super, là.
-Des nids pour humains,
qu'il met en location
grâce à Guillaume, le fondateur
d'une application
dédiée au tourisme écolo.
Et dans le genre locations
non polluantes,
celle-ci est en haut
de la pyramide.
-Donc là, nous avons
tout simplement
le petit coin toilettes.
On s'éclaire
à la bougie.
Musique douce
On a le système
de toilettes sèches.
Ici,
la réserve de sciure.
Et puis on utilise
un système de sacs compostables.
Les clients vont devoir
l'enlever avant de partir.
-150 euros par nuit tout de même,
pas d'eau courante
ni d'électricité,
mais quelques bonnes surprises.
...
-La cerise sur le gâteau.
-C'est là.
-Il faut que tu regardes là.
-Ah, le nid !
Ah ouais, un nid !
-Oui, un nid de chouette.
-Génial.
Ah ouais, super.
-La terrasse.
-Super.
L'intérêt environnemental
de ces hébergements,
c'est que c'est le bon ratio
entre une expérience sympa,
atypique et dépaysante,
et un impact environnemental faible.
Ca coche vraiment les cases.
-Et apparemment,
de plus en plus de touristes
sont intéressés.
Guillaume
a créé son application
il y a deux ans.
Il proposait 50 locations
pour plus de 6000 aujourd'hui.
Elles doivent répondre
à 113 critères écologiques :
émissions de CO2, recyclage,
utilisation de l'eau
et de l'énergie
ou accessibilité.
-Jean-François,
il est "compatible sans voiture".
On peut venir chez Jean-François
directement.
S'il y a une gare pas loin,
Jean-François peut aller
vous chercher à la gare.
On s'est aperçu qu'on pouvait
prendre autant de plaisir
en voyageant en ayant
un impact dérisoire
par rapport aux voyages
qu'on faisait dans le passé.
Et on essaie de créer
les ingrédients techniques
avec notre site
et des imaginaires
pour rendre ça possible
concrètement
et d'être du côté des solutions.
Il s'agit pas juste
de parler de problème.
On essaie de construire
les solutions
pour rendre
ce tourisme agréable.
The Doors, "Money"
...
-Les clients sont forcément
sensibles autant au lieu
qu'à la démarche.
Flore et Lucas
sont tous deux fonctionnaires,
très préoccupés par les questions
environnementales.
Ils sont arrivés de Paris en train.
-Pour les vacances,
on ne prend plus l'avion,
en tout cas, toutes les destinations
qui sont accessibles,
toutes les vacances qu'on fait,
en l'occurrence,
on privilégie le train.
-Il y a pas besoin de choses
très compliquées
quand on peut choisir
des destinations simples,
des modes de voyage plus simples.
Il faut pas se dire
que parce qu'on va aller
à l'autre bout de la planète,
on va complètement se déconnecter.
Il y a pas besoin de ça, en fait.
C'est parti.
-Une autre manière
d'envisager le tourisme
que les défenseurs
des voyages propres tentent
de rendre attractive,
alors que le secteur,
en expansion, représente déjà
au niveau mondial 8 % des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre.
-Pas besoin
de partir loin pour déconnecter.
Le tourisme durable existe.
-C'est vrai, bien sûr.
D'ailleurs, je ne voyage jamais
à l'étranger l'été
parce que je considère
que c'est le pire moment.
Je profite de mon Cantal.
-Vous voyagez pour le travail.
-Oui, mais même l'été,
je voyage pas.
-Vous allez proposer des voyages
à pieds, à vélo, en train ?
-Bien sûr.
C'est une de nos...
-Bientôt, chez vous,
on pourra écouter
le brâme du cerf ?
-On a énormément
de voyages comme ça.
On en vend énormément.
Ca fait des années qu'on le propose,
en vélo et à pieds,
en France.
Mais vous voyez, dire
que le tourisme local
empêche le tourisme de masse,
c'est pas vrai.
-Dans le reportage,
ce qui est intéressant,
c'est de revenir
que ce que j'appelle,
excusez-moi,
l'exotisme en bas de chez soi.
On n'a pas besoin d'être
à l'autre bout de la Terre.
Dans nos territoires,
il y a des choses extraordinaires.
Les Français et les Européens
ont découvert des choses incroyables
après le Covid.
-Le tourisme de demain
sera interrégional ?
-Il peut l'être,
mais il faut que tout le monde
ait le choix et l'accessibilité.
-150 euros la nuit.
Je viens du Nord.
Les populations, tout le monde
peut pas partir en vacances.
Donc les 150 euros,
ce sera pour personne.
-4 Français sur 10.
-Voilà.
Donc qu'est-ce qu'on propose
à ces populations pour rêver ?
Elles en ont le droit.
Nous, on a mis en place,
et ça dure depuis des années,
le train à un euro
pour aller voir la mer,
même une journée.
-Les Allemands ont fait ça.
-Je suis
contente de le redire,
je porte
à l'échelle française
ce que j'appelle le ticket climat,
un abonnement par mois
de 40-50 euros, pour découvrir
partout la France,
prendre le train quand on veut,
notamment le TER,
pour dire que le train,
c'est la clé d'entrée
pour le climat,
pour baisser nos gaz
à effet de serre, pour découvrir
nos territoires et les réconcilier
parce que la fracture territoriale
est très forte en France,
et enfin,
on peut redonner goût
à des emplois de demain,
et notamment le tourisme local.
C'est ce qu'il va falloir préparer.
On va travailler ensemble
sur les métiers
du tourisme local
et durable.
-La solution radicale pour diminuer
son empreinte carbone
serait de voyager
depuis son canapé.
La réalité virtuelle...
-Ah, je déteste ça !
-Moi aussi.
Alors ça...
-Je vous le pose !
-Des voyages de rêve...
-L'antithèse du voyage !
Il vaut mieux
regarder Netflix.
-Laissez-moi terminer !
-Là, pour moi,
c'est le comble de l'horreur !
-Je vous pose la question.
Pompéi
ne se visite plus in situ,
mais bientôt,
se visitera en réalité virtuelle.
-C'est comme Lascaux.
C'est des endroits à protéger
donc il faut empêcher les visiteurs.
Le virtuel peut se justifier.
Mais j'ai vu il y a 10 ans
arriver chez Voyageurs du monde
des gens qui m'ont proposé
des visites virtuelles de safari
en Namibie ou au Botswana,
je leur ai demandé
de repartir.
C'est épouvantable.
-Vous allez peut-être
être d'accord avec moi...
-Le voyage, c'est la rencontre,
l'âme, la spiritualité,
la connexion avec...
-Amen
Vous allez peut-être être
d'accord avec moi.
Le passé est un bon indicateur
pour comprendre l'avenir.
Vous êtes d'accord avec ça ?
-Pas toujours.
Parfois, oui, parfois, non.
Mais j'adore l'histoire.
-Charlotte Epale est allée fouiller
dans les archives de l'INA
et nous a exhumé ceci.
Notre coup d'oeil dans le rétro,
c'est maintenant.
-Sur les berges du canal du Rhône,
à Sète,
La Grande-Motte apporte
aux visiteurs
une curieuse impression
de dépaysement.
Nous nous trouvons ici,
dans la mince bande de terre
comprise entre l'étang
de Mauguio et la mer.
Par temps calme et soleil,
c'est un pays de grand silence
dont le coeur
bat au fil des plaisirs
et des jours.
Mais qui pourrait penser
que ces modestes cabanes
vont bientôt s'effacer,
devant un aménagement
touristique d'envergure.
Ce n'est donc pas en vain
que le Mauguio s'est appelé aussi
Etang de l'Or.
La Grande-Motte sera demain
aussi courue
que les stations balnéaires
les plus célèbres
de la Côte d'Azur.
Cheveux et taureaux
plaquent les accords blancs et noirs
de leur insouciante liberté,
dans cette nature indomptée,
qui respire toujours
du souffle large du Calendal.
Voici des images qui parlent
un langage de traditions
et de quiétude.
Pêcheurs
et chasseurs
demeurent les rois
de cette chaussée virgilienne
sur laquelle le progrès
ne s'est point encore avancé.
Le passeur cher à Verhaeren
y est une accorte passeuse,
et les nouvelles quotidiennes
n'arrivent pas à troubler
la flânerie paresseuse
des canards.
Le temps que Proust
croyait perdu
prend à La Grande-Motte
ses vacances.
Musique douce
...
-La Grande-Motte d'avant le béton,
c'était le bon temps ?
-Absolument, et on a vu
que le progrès,
c'est de construire
et de bétonner,
mais regardez
ce qu'il en est.
-Il y a aussi l'altération
des sites naturels
qui est une pathologie
du tourisme de masse.
-Nous allons nous quitter
sur ces mots,
mais avant,
je vous laisse
en excellente compagnie
avec la jeune et très talentueuse
Camille Etienne,
notre éco-activiste préférée
n'y va pas par quatre chemins.
C'est l'heure de sa Carte verte.
-Maman, j'ai raté l'avion,
et c'est la meilleure chose
que je nous souhaite,
à nous, d'arriver en retard
à cette course effrénée
qui n'a ni fin ni finalité,
d'arriver en retard à ce rendez-vous
qui nous condamne,
de rater notre enterrement,
en quelque sorte.
Et notre salut se trouve
dans l'atterrissage.
Pour toutes ces fois
où on est montés dedans,
où on l'a pas loupé,
cet avion,
il nous a amené à détruire
ce qu'on allait voir.
Aurais-je quand même embarqué
si j'avais su
qu'il m'amènerait
vers des gorges du Verdon sans eau,
des mers de glace sans glace,
une Amazonie sans arbre ?
Oui, c'est dur, c'est injuste,
c'est fatigant.
A coups de milliards,
on s'est assurés
de faire naître en nous le désir
de nous envoyer en l'air.
Je repense à cette publicité.
On la voyait dans le métro,
c'était la publicité d'Air France,
quand on rentrait d'une journée
de cours ou de boulot.
A travers les vitres sales du métro,
c'était écrit en géant :
"Evadez-vous."
Bien sûr que j'avais envie
d'y être moi aussi,
dans cette sublime robe rouge,
à voler puis me réveiller
aux Caraïbes.
On a envie de bouffer le monde
pour être sûr de ne rien y louper,
d'aller voir partout
pour s'assurer de ne rien manquer,
mais cette force du refus,
je l'ai trouvé en apprenant
que ce désir n'était pas le mien.
On s'évade de prison,
pas de son quotidien.
La bonne nouvelle,
c'est qu'on peut se laisser
bouleverser par son voisin,
vivre mille aventures
en partant en stop, en vélo,
en dormant à la belle étoile,
qu'on n'aura pas assez d'une vie
pour découvrir l'Europe en train,
gravir nos sommets,
visiter nos villages,
que la beauté est partout
où on réapprend à la voir.
Il est encore temps
d'atterrir.
Peut-être que l'urgence, maman,
c'est de rater l'avion.
-Merci, Camille.
A signaler,
la sortie de votre livre,
"Pour un soulèvement écologique",
à lire d'urgence.
C'est édité au Seuil.
Pour voyager autrement,
près de chez vous, ce livre,
"Escapades vers le vivant",
signé Alice d'Orgeval,
aux éditions Gallimard.
Toujours chez Gallimard,
si vous voulez aller plus loin,
"A vélo en Europe",
c'est pour vous, Camille,
et pour aller encore plus loin
tout en restant dans son canapé,
"L'an zéro du tourisme",
de Jean Viard et David Medioni
aux Editions de l'Aube.
Je vous l'offre.
-J'adore.
-J'espère que cette courte biblio
répondra à certaines
de vos questions, comme celle-ci :
Comment éviter de passer
de l'usage du monde,
cher à Nicolas Bouvier,
à l'usure du monde ?
Je vous souhaite un très bel été.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...